[Music]
she was the girl of my dreams that was
the moment I knew that it was tough we
met three years ago you are a league of
their own right you gari excellent what
is your favorite drink grapefruit juice
with vodka and three maraschino cherries
hey you want to get out of here yeah it
was the perfect first date so much fun
but I went longer and then I got hugged
oh this is so nice to have a good guy
friend I can't even tell you with a tree
only I could go back and do it with you
differently I could be the granite guys
you want could you tell me what year it
is
it's 2014 I just traveled back in time
right now I have someone to meet what's
your favorite drink
mine is grapefruit juice with vodka and
exactly three maraschino cherries that's
my favorite drink juice what the psycho
I was telling you about you didn't guess
that I was an army brat you already knew
that you're a stalker
soccer's or we're like trench coats you
know underwear and I am clearly wearing
underwear look
[Music]
the photo booth is a time machine this
is gonna be the best night of your life
I can deal with best night of my life
follow what I do ready what's up girl
hmm what's up girl
ahh are you doing a Joker impersonation
this is no this is like what's good all
else fails be an [ __ ] be an [ __ ]
not hard [ __ ] soft [ __ ]
don't forget your leather pants oh my
god
I went full [ __ ] I have no control
over any of this I admit the decision
and then I wake up three years later
with the consequences I thought things
were supposed to happen for a reason
things happen for no reason at all but
they create opportunities the question
is can you recognize that next
opportunity when it matters the most
[Music]
I've got a bomb good one
I got about it's it's fine I'm sorry
about that ruin your match grieving
you'd have a great life
[Music]
[Music]